today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
you know i struggle with hair loss man
and i try and do what i can
i'm on the pills right now honestly
i was just on their website the other
day
keeps i'm talking to you about
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair it's very easy you go to
their site you navigate
based on pictures of what's going on
with you and you make choices to help
yourself
low cost
treatments start at just ten dollars per
month and keeps offers generic versions
prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast
if you're ready to take action and
prevent that hair loss bruh stop that
hair loss fam daddy gang
go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash theo
you want to keep them bangs ganging baby
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash t-h-e-o to get your first
month free
keeps.com theo
today's guest is a
just a real energetic man
and he's got that that thing in him
he got that spunk in him you know he's a
real spunk dragon if you see him
if you beat him spunk would come out
that's who he is
he's a movie actor
and he's a comedian you know him from a
lot of the greats
and um we're here today to get to spend
time with him we're blessed
by this minnesota vikings fan
my friend comedian nick
swartzen for me to set that
[Music]
that light parking me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies
gentlemen that
i and
no i want to just just quickly say brian
callum [ __ ] eat me out
eat me out brian khalid
where are the all right that's what i
wanted to just kick off
yeah that's a starter meal huh that's a
that's a kickoff
that's to eat me out off that's a
slappitizer bro
and would he do it though
i mean
is he that snacky guy i don't know if he
seemed like a real snacker to me
i feel like he would make people do that
to him yeah or i'm generous with my a
noose
my [ __ ] anal tunnel oh yeah
it's just you know
people can just sign up there's a sign
up sheet outside my building really yeah
anybody that's walking by
just jot it down get in there
damn
do you wish you had do you ever wish
that your anus was bigger or do you wish
it was smaller
um i've thought about that every day of
my life when i wake up yeah i just i
touch it and i'm like still kind of
medium
but i think tighter you know what i mean
just for
um a lot of my friends that have you
know big fingers yeah
but um yeah you i mean uh but yeah
entirely you could you could steal
somebody's ring you know like they do on
um
remember on uh i think robin hood when
he kisses the um
the captain's the hand oh yeah
um
yeah he was [ __ ] throbbing yeah he's
as hard as a rock no i don't want my
[ __ ] to be too loose like i want to
feel my [ __ ] you know what i mean i
don't want to just fall out yeah just go
awol yeah like somebody just throwing
them on your doorstep like an amazon guy
yeah yeah i don't want him just [ __ ]
swan diving when i take a [ __ ] and like
clean landing
i wanted to i want to feel it yeah oh
wow huh yeah
damn you're like a real outdoorsman yeah
i'm very thirsty yeah you're very old
yeah [ __ ] i'll take a [ __ ] anywhere i
think in the future people [ __ ] will
be a thing of the past actually
defecating as a human like if you see
somebody go in a room by themselves
to have
special desecration or whatever it's
called desecration that's desecration
leave their body defecation isn't it
defecation yeah yeah desecration i think
is
um when you put your turtleneck on
backwards oh damn yeah i think that's
what it is
um
but damn dog no the futures is gonna be
like eye toilets or something or it's
like apple will drop like
some new thing yeah wonder what's gonna
happen it's exciting to think about is
it yeah
yeah i hope apple's listening
if steve jobs ghost is here we gotta get
out a [ __ ] ouija board wake that
[ __ ] up dude where's your eye
toilet [ __ ] dead guy
you just press a button and the meal
leaves your stomach yeah you put your
phone like just put it right against
your stomach and it just [ __ ] absorbs
it
and then
it sends it right to brendan schaub's
mouth
it just appears ben and shaw be like
eating at some [ __ ] stupid restaurant
and then just [ __ ] just fills his mouth
like a [ __ ] italian chipmunk
just harboring nuts for the winter
oh
and he gets back in his leopard-skinned
miata that he bought for eight million
dollars because he didn't doesn't know
how to buy things
when you child when you every time you
floor it in there you can hear an
endangered species die i feel like you
can hear
many special animals kill themselves
yeah dude it runs on ebola
[Laughter]
eboliato that's the new [ __ ] car
brendan drives um no but i think in the
future everyone will wear like a
colostomy bag you'll just empty out i
think actually having to go to a room to
like
because it's crazy when you think about
it i'm going to go off to a private room
and get like uh
liquids or solids out of my body it
almost seems like you're like a bad
magician
right yeah yeah but it's a trick that
everybody knows and the trick smells
yeah yeah like if you pull a rabbit out
of a hat doesn't smell unless a rabbit's
dead
yeah yeah that's right
bad magic and it's just some guys
pulling dead rabbits out of a hat
how is that not a show there's every
other [ __ ] show on the air it's so
stupid i was like quarantining and [ __ ]
back in the day i can't even say that
which is weird so yeah you left out of
columbus and what
i left out of columbus and i didn't know
what was happening like everybody else i
was like what is happening
and uh
you know people were just it was up in
the air and then uh
i um went and just they're like you got
a quarantine so i came back to la and
got my [ __ ] and then i went back to
minnesota where i'm from yeah and
quarantined in my sister's basement
which was a house that i i bought her
so your basement my basement she i
remind her of that every time i step
foot in that [ __ ] place anyway i'll
digress on that
but
it was just weird because then it was
like there were murder hornets and like
all this weird [ __ ] kept dropping and
then i left at the pentagon reveal that
they're aliens they're like no there's
proof there's aliens people like yeah
yeah cool anyway what's going on with
this disease like nobody cared about
anything yeah they dropped murder
hornets on us i don't even know what the
[ __ ] that is yeah i feel like they kind
of like it was a time where like they're
going to slip other things out while
people are heavy yeah totally they're
like oh they're looking that way
dude
there's a lot of like distraction going
on
well that comes to my point so i was in
quarantine
and uh i got minnesota and what are you
doing there are you working during the
day are you doing anything are you doing
emails i use my [ __ ] mind okay so i
just sat there and i read books
and i got caught up on netflix shows
and i journaled
and i caught up with a lot of friends
and i did some podcasts and [ __ ] or like
phoners and stuff
but um i just sat there and like really
thought about my life
and uh you know what i wanted to
accomplish in my next chapter you know
what i mean yeah so i didn't drink or
anything i was [ __ ] sober kai dude
wow
yeah i didn't [ __ ] you were living
clean out there now where you were doing
a gym were you elliptical in or anything
no i just did push-ups it was like a
kind of a it was like a
prison
it's not like you're incarcerated yeah i
was a prison with netflix your sister's
upstairs
she's upstairs and my nieces and nephews
and stuff and i was like just don't even
don't come in this sanctuary yeah yeah
and i took shits i'm not gonna lie yeah
and uh the dog would run in and he would
watch me poop and then he would be like
all right i'm this is this is like the
third time in like half hour you're like
he's like re-run
yeah
and so then i got a message from expedia
and they were like
are you ready for your trip to key west
i had [ __ ] forgot that i booked a
trip to key west that december before
covert or anything i was like i've
always wanted to go to key west yeah and
just kick it you know i've read
hemingway i like the show bloodline
so i went to key west florida i left
there and then i went to south carolina
and hung out with danny mcbride for like
oh yeah yeah i love danny i almost moved
there he's like you gotta move here dude
yeah and i almost did but i went down to
key west
and uh i was gonna go back up to south
carolina but i stayed in key west i was
supposed to be there for 10 days i
stayed for a year and a half
in [ __ ] key west i was there a year
and a half
that's not a joke and what did you start
like a not a farm but you do like a um
job or something did you get hired
anywhere nope
what i just tuned out i was just
everything was so [ __ ] bonkers in
2020 that i was just over it dude so i
just stayed down there and it was so
removed from everything like nobody gave
a [ __ ] i had no idea what day it was
after a while
and i just stayed i just kicked it were
you partying were you sailing were you i
partied initially and sailed initially
yeah and then i just
[ __ ] had a couple of [ __ ] pops and
then i would just listen to the song
sailing yeah by christopher cross and
that was a lot easier
sailing
[Music]
no but it was awesome though like nobody
was on twitter nobody was like yeah
everybody was just like island life and
i just fell in love with it
and was it like um were you doing um any
employment at all are you just i didn't
do [ __ ] i did nothing did you try to get
a job did you fill out the application i
was just over it i thought about some
[ __ ] and i was like planning on coming
home like what like real estate or what
were you considering
no i was gonna like shave my pubes and
just make dream catchers or some [ __ ]
like that's what key west is like like
after a year i didn't even own clothes
i just wore like butterflies is there
government down there i feel like it's
just like basically people down there
just
like obviously these people hating
native americans and everybody because
they're they're trying to get out of
america is a lot of cubans there's a
latino there what is it it's kind of
everything i mean it's local it's
uh i mean it's you know it's
a lot of tourists it's a big tourist
spot you know so it's a lot of people
driving from florida and there's a lot
of fishing
there's a lot of fishing and there's a
lot of like snow birds but it's funny
because when i landed my buddy picked me
up
and he goes welcome to the island of
misfit toys
and i go what does that mean he goes
you'll see
and i didn't know what that meant and
then after a little bit i was like oh
yeah
like everybody's just going rogue dude
like everyone's got a story everybody
that i met was like yeah i came down
here like on a connection with the
flight and then i just stayed for like
20 years
like it's just the best
like relief yeah i was on the airline
they lost my family like the airline
lost your family
yeah i was flying over key west and then
i decided [ __ ] i'm just gonna parachute
out of this [ __ ] and just
open the door
but it was awesome it was just it was
[ __ ] crazy i can't believe i was
there that long wow it was so fun and
i'm not the coolest people all the
locals are great really yeah now is
there a lot of cause you seem like a
kind of place where people are sneaking
out they're getting like a lot of times
you see on american greed the guy ends
up down in key west is there like a lot
of hidden like
people that could have been doing
murders or anything like that down there
i feel like it's a lot of like kind of
like you'll never catch me type of
people i mean you know i didn't i wasn't
like a part of that scene but i mean i
it exists it's like the show bloodline
have you seen that
half the first episode the first season
is [ __ ] dope but it's a lot of hiding
bodies
i didn't see that i mean i hid
a lot of big garbage bags that were
really heavy but i didn't look inside
yeah so it could have been i'm just
gonna say
it was
a bunch of um iguanas
that's how i'm gonna visualize it did
you see like um that speak english and
you'll help did you feel that
did you feel i feel like it's a lot of
people wearing eye patches and a lot of
people like her if you knew what
happened you know you'd be fine lad you
couldn't your motor was a r you know i
feel like it's like a lot of like there
is that like there's like those bars
yeah then there's like heavy tourist
bars
and then there's uh is there a
margaritaville
um yeah i'm almost sure there was i
never went to it they're like the
margaritavilles like the fat tuesdays is
there a chico's is that fat tuesdays
what's the one that's like the big and
tall clothing store
obese ricks oh bees rick yeah
no um i don't know yeah yeah
dawns
thick ricks
hey welcome to the thick rick's the
guy's just shocking
he's like a mr potato head heavy on the
potato yeah hey
mr potato you mind just pouring some
ketchup on my body
they don't know they don't have cologne
they just have gravy
they just [ __ ]
yeah oh what are you wearing uh that's
uh
sausage
that's some stouffer's new cologne
yeah why not oh damn no but it's one of
those places jason does a deodorant
oh my god that's amazing oh my god these
condoms have real sheepskin in
them it's chewy
oh man oh no the lamb here is great oh
my god this shirt has chocolate chips on
it
um
yeah but it's one of those places where
the dive bars like i just didn't really
go to them because it's kind of like you
said it's one of those things where i
was told this where you walk in and
they're like
who are you
like eye patch [ __ ] eye
patches yeah some guy takes his eye out
of his mouth because it's wet it's just
gotten wet enough to put back in socket
yeah it makes it sound like
yeah because it's just been sweating but
yeah but there's a lot of great bars
sandbar is awesome it's like the sports
bar there i was there a lot
and uh it's just cool man everything you
think you were missing out on the world
did you feel no i was a big i don't know
anybody else that just kind of went to a
place and was like this is what i'm
gonna do
yeah i mean i don't know who else did i
mean i was there just chilling but it
was perfect because every time i would
look at my phone
or look at twitter
it was just there was always something
[ __ ] bonkers happening like no day
was chill and it would like stress me
out and i'm like oh god
yeah
so then i was like get me the [ __ ] out
of here
were people down there like in were they
uh
by is it a lot of people trying to
escape the pandemic was it people
believing the pandemic was it a lot of
like deniers or was it just
what was the vibe down there it was a
lot of you know it's a lot of locals and
it's a lot of people that
you know there were people that kind of
believed it and kind of were you know
not believed it but like we're like oh
yeah no like you got to be careful right
i mean nobody was
like reckless you know nobody was
walking around
sneezing into a [ __ ] megaphone yeah
but um i don't even know what's
happening straight into a baby's ass
yeah get that baby
sneezy jefferson
but uh yeah i know it was knees into him
and his arms go like this yeah
the needles cries blood out of his eyes
no uh no it was it was chill but you
know there was they took your
temperature and people wore masks and
but a lot of people came to key west
lake get away from the masks i hear
there's a lot of like risque sex parties
and stuff down there did you see any of
that i didn't see i had heard stuff but
that's kind of one reason why i was
intrigued i'm not i'm not going to a sex
party yeah because every party i go to
is a sex party
no um like a judge i hear it's like a
real seemingly mardi gras down there you
know like that's kind of what you hear
there are semen fights those break out
at happy hour yeah yeah so it's just you
know a lot of [ __ ] spider webs i'm
the king of new york
[Laughter]
but
no it wasn't as wild
but also this is
post covid so pre covert i heard it was
a lot crazy they have a thing called
fantasy fest
and they have stuff like that where
they're like dude
it's there's no rules it's just
completely insane and is fantasy fest is
it a gay festival because it's because
it's also no it's like anything
it's a lot of like swingers like that
was kind of a vibe that i got it's a lot
of people that are
like down like married couples from ohio
that came down for a weekend oh they
wheeling them out they're just now
they're wearing toilet seats and they
have all they always have some brother
shows up in a tony gwynn jersey and like
oh this dude yeah this dude's getting on
base and then they're like is that
minute ball and it just might be
that's some piece to both those guys
they've passed have they yeah
oh yeah at fantasy fest
oh they started coming all their organs
out because they were [ __ ] so much
bleep
that's my spleen
yeah sir you're an organ donor
thank you you donated to my butt bank oh
yeah
[Music]
um
but yeah it was great man and then i
came back it like kind of changed my
whole view of everything so i came back
briefly to los angeles for a couple
weeks to shoot a commercial
and uh just makes a little
for what is it for boston market it was
for wendy's
yeah i was like
just only online and i went back to my
place in la and i got a condo it's nice
you know it's chill
and i looked at all my stuff and i'm
like why do i have all this stuff
i don't need this [ __ ]
and i [ __ ] got rid of like
so much of my clothes my shoes
i got rid of my like i had a rolex i had
a diamond chain i got rid of all of it
all of it and i was just like i don't
need it and that's what was cool about
key west is like i was there for that
long and i had maybe
eight shirts
two pairs of shorts flip-flops and a
pair of shoes damn and i was happy as
[ __ ] dude i was like why do i don't need
all this [ __ ] you know what i mean it
was really cool and it really like
made me realize how much when you just
have so much [ __ ] i got rid of my car
five years ago yeah and uh like the more
stuff you have i mean i live in a
neighborhood where i can walk everywhere
but
you know i just got rid of [ __ ] it was
just i donated it you know what i mean
and it felt cathartic you're saying it
was cathartic and it's like if you if
you're out there and you're listening
yeah
like just look around your you know
where you live just go like do i need
something need this
blender you don't need that yeah you
don't need a [ __ ] fourth facts
machine yeah you have 40 bath towels
yeah yeah that's too much you have one
body
yeah you have one body yeah and i mean
people in key west would be like oh yeah
dude you're still here it's dope and i
go yeah and they're like dude do you
need another shirt and i'm like
yeah
and they're like all right and we would
like barter
i'm like here's my spleen and i'd
[ __ ] jerk a spleen into their [ __ ]
grill
but uh
yeah it was just it was just are you
really humming bats down there is it the
kind of place where you're going to
offer you save that more for the
mainland what's going on down there be
honest with me with what looks like if i
get to island if i go out to an island
dude i feel like the first thing i want
to do when i get there is
spray out you know just
unleash the seed bust 100 son yeah i
mean i i just it's like it's almost like
doing it's like your own little
christopher columbus it's your own
little
whatever that place is called chesapeake
or whatever where they land at plymouth
rock plymouth rock dude yeah
no i mean it was i played with my
jenny's a couple times i pretended like
my balls were like an island and then my
dick was like a palm tree
so i just squeeze it and then make the
tree
unleash a [ __ ] blizzard here
but yeah i know i [ __ ] teach you
was it um it was just like
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do it's
like the movie office space which is
great if you haven't seen it watch it
but there's the scene where peter
um played by ron livingston gets
hypnotized he's like a nine to five
corporate yeah i remember that and um
nine to five dude and he gets hypnotized
and he
goes into his zone and has this clarity
oh damn and he just
the more he doesn't give a [ __ ] the more
things happen to him that are good
and there's a scene where his buddy goes
hey man
peter what's going on with you
and peter just goes
have you ever done nothing
it's so much better than you think it is
and that's kind of how i was because i
was
you know i i started comedy when i was
19 and i was immediately on tv and
toured my whole life
and i'm 45
and i was filming and touring and
filming and touring and i never just
stopped and like took a breath because
everywhere i went i would do shows so i
was always kind of it's a little
stressful you know so it just was
constant so when i got there i think
that's why i stayed so long
because as i was just like oh i've never
just been like
i don't want to go through my emails i
don't want to check twitter i don't want
to go
on facebook i don't want to do this i
just want to like wake up
wave to the [ __ ] sun go get a [ __ ]
cocktail go to the [ __ ] beach it's
right there it was just so awesome and
the people were so great so so many cool
people people struggle
people struggle if you even look in the
bible or if you look at uh even as old
movies or anything
you could definitely see a lot of people
are struggling so
it's not shocking that you might need
help
and if you can't get help in your area
or if you don't want to go to a brook
and mortar building because you might be
nervous or scared better help is
available
that's right
better help
available worldwide there's a broad
range of expertise available
better help give them a call they'll
assess your needs and match you with a
counselor a real counselor
that's a licensed professional therapist
so it's not
this is real deal this is people that
can help you
you can start communicating in under 48
hours
visit betterhelp.com t-h-e-o
that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and tpw listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
theo a lot of people wait till the end
of the end of the world to get
athletic or to take care of their health
you see somebody 90 years old they going
for a run
first run
like what are you doing brenda
what's up hank get out the street dawg
but times have changed man that's right
that's why you need the new
peloton bike
that's right working out never feels
like a chore
there's always something new to discover
peloton makes fitness entertaining and
fun
and right now you can get 350 off the
peloton bike it's their best offer of
the year
visit
onepeloton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
to learn more
350 off the peloton bike at one
peloton.com terms apply
did you learn anything about yourself
kind of in that time because it is a
real because i i i get afraid to take a
break sometimes you know
well i mean i learned that i to
decompress and to like take care of
myself
and uh
also just
just
you know i mean like again being 45 you
know the world just changed so much like
we grew up without social media and grew
up without all this [ __ ] and all this
stuff and like i said like 2020
2021 we're just so it's just still
insane but it's like it was just system
overload essentially yeah so i was like
when i was quarantined and i was stoned
sober i was like
oh
i want to go back to like reading and
like
just hanging out with like being with
myself you know and not having stimulus
and all these people and all this
[ __ ] would you read you reading
books zines what were you reading i read
[ __ ] zines
i read books
yeah
i read yeah i can read i think i used to
read outdoor american can you pull that
up colin don't pull it up
unlike callan and shop i can read there
you go outdoor america right there
budget
set up for fall walleye
go back to that go back to the dime with
the walleye huh
and what's the article at the top
dude look at you you want to catch your
brown eye hey here we go
uh the old cold water crappie huh oh
[ __ ]
where and how to catch fall crappy oh
grab your crabs question of my life and
where did you do any fishing tours down
there
yeah why not like everybody there has a
boat so you want to go on the boat and i
love the ocean i love the water it's
just that to me is really cathartic do
you jump in the water when you get out
there you stay in the boat no i walk on
the water i'm jesus
yeah of course
yeah i get in the [ __ ] water
it's a trip dude you go out like way out
and you it's still walkable yeah like
they're like sand bars they call them
damn yeah it was just you really lived
it up so was there a point where uh i
would take naps yeah i'll take like
three naps a day oh
it was so awesome
dude i took a nap
i think this is two days ago probably
the first nap i've taken in
a couple years maybe
it was so nice it was like only about 14
minutes but it was so nice i feel like
it's hard to sleep at night it's easier
to sleep get real good rest on a nap do
you think that
yeah i think i mean i've learned with
all the stuff like i've got a holistic
doctor and people like
that you know turn me onto certain
things
and they were like listen to your body
they were like listen if your body's
tired you should [ __ ] lie down you
know it's just 10 minutes 15 minutes
yeah you know if you're hungry like eat
you know what i mean if your body's like
hey i want to eat yeah like just grab a
piece of fruit grab some [ __ ] veggies
damn yeah so what brought you back is
there now now that you're back in in los
angeles and in maine land america do you
feel like there's anything that like
was there stuff that you missed do you
feel like you
want to do
more work do you like you want to go
back there like what do you kind of feel
now i wanted to i mean i wanted to
retire i wasn't planning on coming home
really and then i met i mean every day i
would meet fans and take photos and
they're all like what are you working on
next you know when's your next stand up
special when are you touring again all
my twitter dates got canceled it's
covered
and uh
i realized then i would go like i think
i'm going to retire and then people to
look on their face to be like
what
i'm like
yeah i don't know i think i might just
live here and they're like
you can't do that
and then you know like a lot of my
friends and people are like dude you
can't you're [ __ ] 44 at the time
you can't just
cash in now
and uh they're like you gotta like keep
going and then i talked to my agents and
[ __ ] and they were like yeah where have
you been yeah
and i like you they could hear parrots
in the background and i'm eating a
tarantula i don't even know what is
going on
and
so they're like just come home dude just
come on man you can't quit and i had a
it was frustrating so i had a new
special before covet i had all this
stuff so
i
took a little bit more time and then i
was like i gotta come home and i got
offered two movies wow i start filming
in february you do yeah and then i
started to do stand-up again and
so i i i missed it you know what's the
movie going to be about
there are two sequels one is a sequel to
a movie called the binge
which was on amazon which i i had not
seen it but my friend was producing it
and they offered me the sequel and i
watch it and it's it's
funny dude there's some really funny
[ __ ] vince vaughn's in it this is a
really good cast it's about
like the movie the purge you know that
it's like a big franchise oh yeah yeah i
saw the purge where one day you can like
kill people
yeah this one is
it's in the future and it's like the
world is sober
and one day everything's legal every
drug alcohol everything's legal damn
yeah so it's like what would you do if
you had one day uh
and then we'll get to this question that
came in if you had one day what would
you do where everything's legal
what would i do what drug wise yeah or
anything
if anything was legal
everything is kind of legal
i mean if you get away with it no i mean
i don't know i'm not gonna rob a house
or kill i don't know i mean i don't
think i could eat anybody
i mean
you got to kill something you know
it's not that hard these days to find
somebody to kill i don't think
i would probably i don't i i couldn't my
friend killed somebody
uh by choice
or you just made it oopsie i mean it's
hit you know i'm not trying to somebody
fell on a gun it's not i mean i'm not
trying to like you know
oh god no you already opened the can of
worms but you know
oh some guy actually raked himself to
death in his own yard that's interesting
he just punched his dick into his ass
until he bled out oh she just cried
merry christmas
bring that image home to your family oh
bro there's been times where i just
wanted to climb into my own ass man yeah
that's what i mean i did that in key
west and just disappear yeah you just
hide in a little [ __ ] warm cage yeah
and just reach out with one hand and cut
the lights off like that yep hold it
just hold it over the hole yeah
yeah
um
but yeah so i'm doing that and then a
sequel to a movie i did called uh the
buddy games me and josh to male and dax
shepard olivia munn
it was a big uh it was a big hit it's on
video on demand and you can it's not a
bunch of strategies we'll never see it
but no i thought it was good you will
but uh not on an airplane probably i
feel like people rated r bro do you feel
like it's interesting how movies now
have kind of disappeared a little it's
like since the theaters are gone it's
different
um yeah but they're coming back i mean
uh movies are still i mean they're i
feel bad because a lot of the movies
that were like huge movies
um like dune and ghostbusters and there
was like a handful of them that are
being released but
you know it just it [ __ ] was a [ __ ]
block so my movie buddy games was
supposed to be in the theaters and we
got c blocks
but check it out i will check out buddy
games because i like i like a title like
that buddy games it's fun dude yeah so
we're doing a sequel to that so i'm
filming i would love that dude i could
see you doing like a a good movie for
you i think would be doing like
something with armadillos or like night
animals i've been offered that a lot
yeah this is they've offered me
armadillo the movie armadillo
um the horror movie horror movie are you
joking around no man i don't joke about
armadillos a lot of people do you could
you you think you could have offered a
porno armadildo oh did you really damn
dude it just comes out at night mm-hmm
right i need your bum yup comes out
while you're sleeping
it's
and it's the size of an arm
it has a watch around its neck
dude that is some flavor flav right
there but you know armadillos can jump
really high can we get a video of that
please
okay there's the [ __ ] armadillo look
at that bad girl huh shorty thick huh
don't they she looks mexican kind of
with her hair like that
what don't they have like um
like scales or something what's on their
back don't they fold up into a ball
uh yeah they do because i was at a park
and i picked it up i thought and i
dunked it and then if this thing died
it unveiled itself
look at that dillo i think they go by
dillo huh
yeah
that's what diplo the dj he used to be
called deluxe he's an armadillo i think
oh i could see him being at that joke
they're very nocturnal uh can we see uh
the video of the jumping armadillo
please yeah that was what we wanted
initially
not the [ __ ] thing eating lip leaves
or vagina
okay is it standing up
that's a man that's a wow
that's how bad my vision is
oh oh she tased it's [ __ ] huh i don't
know that thing definitely
somebody did she chased the labia that
thing got a tater salad enema right
there you saw that
bro
somebody freaking
got dipped in the freaking
got a little bit of bowl slaw dude we
got armadillo right here y'all check it
out
i'm going to slow down
so we can look at it look at this okay
check this out i got this air horn right
here oh that's not cool i'm gonna see
what happens when i blow it at the
armadillo
i can't see what happened
i gotta go back
[Laughter]
can we zoom in on the screen some right
here
i'm gonna see what happens when i blow
it at the armadillo
dude my god
you know in the future they're they're
doing a thing now and the future is now
and they're doing a thing where a lot of
armadillos they're getting the scales
off of them so it's just the body
and you can because people can have them
more as pets and then unbelievable
the way that they're starting to
just get a cat
they don't want that they have to have
an armadillo they [ __ ] are these
idiots who are these people i don't know
rich people probably people making your
movie probably brendan is probably a
[ __ ] kennel of our [ __ ] dillos
what a [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah
rogan has a fleet
he's got an army i'm sure he has a
couple we had a question another
question about hollywood that came in
what else do we got
what up theo what up swarty yo what up
morning from phoenix arizona yeah the
phoenix had a little quick question
uh who's more fun to work with
jennifer aniston
or david spade
to me they're kind of both equal on the
looks both pretty good looking yeah
anderson seems sneaky funny though
spade's obvious funny
okay that's depending on the mood you're
in but there we go
thanks dude i love you call me sporty
that's my nickname dude i love uh that
that guy a looks like me if i were a
little handsomer right and um that guy
moved to aries very
he's living kind of a joe dirt existence
kind of did you catch that at all yeah i
caught a little bit of dirt there moved
to arizona he for sure has it which is
where spade is from he's got a dillo
necklace oh
um spade anderson
interesting question they are both very
different you're accurate on anastom
being sneaky funny she's very funny
um
she's got better hair than david ooh
yeah and hers um
is very majestic
david
smells like funyuns
yeah okay but david is very funny yeah
but i'm i'm going to give aniston the
edge
because you well when you're in a scene
with anderson your eye when you look at
david you've got to look down
and he's kind of like a lawn gnome
oh he's got that downhill vibe yeah but
in a nice way like a nice funny little
little lawn now
what about um
were you down there when norm passed
away
yeah that was awful norm was one of my
best friends
that was awful really yeah that was my
buddy todd calling i woke up from a nap
and i look at my phones my friend todd
i'm like hey what's up
he goes uh
we're just taking a nap and i go yeah
what's up he goes uh you haven't checked
your phone have you and i go no
and he goes norm mcdonald died
and i go
what no
and he goes yeah and it was one of the
few times in my life
i just hung up the phone and immediately
started sobbing
and i sobbed for like a half hour i just
completely lost it yeah he was like
really like one of my close friends and
it was like waiting for a fight huh it
was awful dude it was just and then i
found out like he had cancer for a long
time didn't tell anybody and it it was
hard it's still really hard everyone's
pretty shook by it do you remember the
last time that you had seen him
um i hadn't seen him for a while
but uh the last time i saw him
that like at a bar by our place
and uh
he would watch he was a big gambler
but um the last time i talked to him
i was quoting when i was quarantined in
minnesota he would uh i'd text him and i
go
hey what's up dude and he goes
who's this
and i he would do this all the time i go
it's [ __ ] nick dude he goes
hey nikki
what uh what are you doing
and i'm like nothing i'm quarantined and
he goes ah he didn't stand after
and i'm like no the [ __ ] i wasn't saying
stand up
and he goes why that what's your plan
and i go i don't know i'm gonna kick it
here and then i think i'm gonna go to
key west and i go
i might just retire though and just move
to reno and just get like a residency
and then i'll just live in reno and just
work there just be like an old comic
yeah and he goes the sword of god he
goes
ah that's a that's a good idea i'm gonna
go yeah i don't know whatever he goes
that nah
maybe i'll join you we'll both headline
reno
and i go
dude reno's [ __ ] a mess i go no i
don't want to do it
so i go to key west a month later he
calls him he goes
hey
what are you doing and i go i don't know
i'm in key west what's up with you and
he goes
uh
when are you going to reno and i go
dude that was a joke i'm not moving the
[ __ ] reno and retiring it's like a
comic and he goes ah [ __ ] i thought i
thought it was a good idea
and i'm like no
and so that's the last time i talked to
him
and then his
um close close for his closest friend
lori jo
i hit her up after norman passed and i
was like hey are you doing okay
and she goes one of the last things
before
norm died one of the last things he
talked about was moving to reno with you
no yeah and i go are you serious she
goes yeah he was like
he really wanted to do that
and i was like oh and then i made me cry
again
and uh yeah it was just
that was norm it was really it's awful
damn i'll tell you i have so many norm
stories but this is one of my favorites
and um
i was on tour me sandler spade rob
schneider and norm was kind of like the
wild card he would pop in for certain
dates
so we're and uh i believe mohican son in
connecticut we're backstage everyone's
in santa's green room talking shooting
[ __ ] and me and norman in the hallway
hanging out and um i don't know why i
did this
uh this long hallway and this guy walks
in
uh way down the hallway walks in the
door and i'm like looking and you know
we're always kind of suspicious about
people who come backstage
and i go
i think that guy's a gun
and uh normal goes
what
and i go i think that guy's a [ __ ]
gun dude and he's like oh my god and he
runs into sandler's room and he goes
there's a gun
there's a man with a gun and i was like
no no no there's not there's not i was
no no i'm joking there's not and he goes
no no no next time there's a catholic
gun and stanley goes what the [ __ ] is
the guy with the [ __ ] gun and spade's
like oh no what the [ __ ] what's good and
i'm like no there's no gun there's no
gun i just it was i was making like a
joke just for norm and norm's like
what how is that a joke and i'm like i
don't i don't know
and sam was like
stanley was like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you and i'm like
i don't know man spade's like yeah real
cool man and i'm like
i'm just gonna go to my room and norm's
like yeah i thought there was a gun i'm
sorry nick nick said it
i'm like
lord real buzz when the guy walked past
it was a security guard
[Laughter]
but yeah so he really did have a gun
he didn't have a gun but he just looked
like somebody that would have a gun
yeah well people use guns for security
man
it was just not a good joke on my part
especially poor norm did you guys ever
work together or not
we did those shows together and we did
like
oh i got a norm story too um you know we
never like we're on stage together like
[ __ ] bonnie and clyde or whoever
i was at uh i don't think it's called is
it bonnie and clyde
i don't know
um
we can hear a security guard he's doing
this [ __ ]
oh dude yeah bro he had i don't know if
he eats at like a um
trough or something but he has the worst
who norm are the security guards bowel
movements the
security guard here and he's a parking
attendant but his shirt says security
i'm like
that's a yeah
sounds like no one's safe from that
bathroom yeah
but he's in there about probably if i go
in there
he's in there one out of two times when
i go
oh really yeah because he has a problem
yeah yeah he needs an armadillo
oh he closes up that drain
no [ __ ] scales
feels clean
no scales baby this [ __ ] is clean boy
damn i got my baby a damn freaking
scaleless dilla baby
god damn i can't that is that a real
thing look at it people want scaleless
armadillos you bet i'm looking at teddy
tonight son damn boy
i'll eat half my own [ __ ] son i'm
[ __ ] if i'm looking at scaleless
dilla son it's on baby [ __ ]
it is on bro i will [ __ ] eat a pecan
out of my cousin's ass baby you feel me
listen christmas morning
let's go elvis presley um you think you
could do a good elvis presley
impersonation
i could make an attempt all right i
don't know if i would ever use it on
anything i'll have
all right
she
[Music]
hey
then he dies he goes into stroke oh damn
dude
and that's uh who is that that's
benedict cumberbatch who was that yeah
that was benedict cumberbatch doing
elvis presley
um
and that was steven seagal and that was
aaron gonzalez they hear aaron gonzalez
in person yeah that's correct go pads
yeah um
no so i went to i had to go to this
casino one time with norm right
gambling man no he was playing on the
show adam eager was there and i somehow
got booked in the feature right
so norm's headline and
i felt like norm was on pills or he was
way a little bit lit but i don't know if
that's true some people say he never did
any drugs i don't know he seemed like he
was off
he took pills but he could have been
yeah he could have just been having a
this was like he had cancer for a while
right so who knows uh i don't even know
so but this is when i was alive and you
know in my past
so what happened was i
go on stage and i ran the light right i
was like
but yeah and it was literally in a barn
like attached to a casino like the place
where you could hear like there were
like live births like there was a lot
going on you know from animals or people
i mean who knows you know thick thing
you just heard the sludge oh you hurt
you hurt some [ __ ] sludge you hurt you
let the bodies hit the floor there was
nobody catching these things they were
being born right you know it was just a
lot of uh
falling they were free falling
i didn't even hit the ground not a
skinny puppy you know a lot of babies
that were fart powered oh yeah
that's my son you know oh a little robo
fart just that kind of
so who books this gig helen keller so
anyway
he goes out there and he's he is like
you can barely even hear him it's ba
he's just kind of garbling his words
right right so anyway
the next day
we're all downstairs jerry mathers is
there too
okay what
no i swear jerry mathers is beaver from
leave it to be bring him a picture of
jerry mathers please also that's a real
show for all the kids out there leaves
called leave it to beaver yeah and
beaver was like the rascal son right oh
all show old shows are porns now right
there he is right there
yeah
and uh what the [ __ ] was he doing giving
birth to eddie haskell bro he was the
same show and yeah and eddie haskell
died recently r.i.p very sad but um
young violence uh i'm not sure what it
was i think it was miss live in a nice
neighborhood i think it was miss
applebaum or whatever he whoever the
teacher was he was always at odds with
you know yeah miss crabapple or whatever
it was but anyway uh
so i get up i i i get up there um oh in
the morning
oh so mathers is there right and i said
to him i was like he's like i was just
talking i was a huge fan i had signed i
bought an autographed picture of him
when i was a kid i had it on my wall at
home i had a jerry mathers autographed
picture my wallet that is gross because
his name was theodore and my name
theodore oh that's right so i was just
keyed in right so anyway
uh
i wish this story would end
you were like leave it to sleazer dude
so anyway i'm [ __ ] throwing on your
[ __ ] eggnog
where do you live i said i live in santa
monica he goes i used to get some [ __ ]
in santa monica that's exactly what he
said bro
yes so right there i'm a little shook
i'm excited you know i'm still excited
that it's him but i'm a little shook
right but anyway in the morning norm's
downstairs we'll have to play in this
poker tournament that's part of the
weekend deal the package
and norm's like man a lot of hot chicks
here hun i'm looking around it's like
nobody's
that nobody's hot in this area right
there hasn't been anybody hot here if
somebody here were hot you would know
about it immediately they'd be on a
calendar they would be on the news yeah
they would be on the news yeah
general yeah that would be on the news
bro
yeah if a decent strand of jeans pass
through this town the [ __ ] fire
alarms would go off right there has not
been they would be up from the news to a
milk carton in like a week there has not
been a a unique strand of gtac to roll
through this area
in [ __ ]
since [ __ ] what norm was definitely
on pills if he was like looking around
here right ah there's some
tail here yeah so i thought he was
serious right because i don't really
know him i'm like yeah man there
definitely is and then he goes [ __ ] no
there isn't
and it just shook me
that's that's so him that's amazing
he like baited me into believing that he
yeah and then he [ __ ] pulled the rug
out yeah
did he [ __ ] no there isn't it's so harsh
you never i mean i was one of his good
friends for
a long time i'm talking like 15 years
wow and i still was like
i could kind of gauge but sometimes i
was like
what is he saying right but he uh he was
out of his
out of this world did he chase a lot of
women did he have a wife or anything no
i never met a wife he has a son dylan
who's really cool so he must have did
sex once at least i mean i never saw he
was addicted he was a big gambler dude
really yeah
and he
he had a bit
he
he always did so many gay jokes but i
never knew him to be gay or anything but
he had a joke he was on letterman
and uh or no it was conan and he goes
he is promoting his book and he goes
yeah it's not a memoir but uh
and it's just uh it's a book
and he goes uh
you know i don't talk about being deeply
a deeply closeted gay man and conan goes
what you're gay and he goes what
now why'd you say that because we just
said he goes now i'm i'm deeply closeted
and he goes so you're not good he's like
no no i'm straight as an arrow
he goes and then he goes and i'm
paraphrasing forgive me but he goes you
know deeply closeted means the guy's gay
but he's so gay he won't admit it he
hides it
and uh he's like yeah no i'm straight
[Laughter]
it was such a [ __ ] good bit again i
[ __ ]
uh paraphrased it but it's on youtube
that's funny man yeah he was great
yeah i watched one of his clips and he
was on i think the view did you see that
clip
no when they're trying to get him to
like he's trying to be very realistic
the show's like ultra liberal and he's
just trying to be just a realist like
yeah that's how he was yeah and they're
like they won't they're like you'll
never be back on this show they're all
joking about it and stuff anyway he
wouldn't because he wasn't like just
kind of conforming to whatever like
i don't know just some ridiculous story
why would they have him on i don't know
that's so weird like he's so not i can
see him doing it like if they offered it
to him but i can't here we go let's get
a little bit of it that uh uh the
democrats don't steal the election from
the uh the winner you know but who knows
you like george bush i love george bush
man he's a good man decent you know none
of this
[Applause]
and he's uh you know he's not a
a lie or a crook murderer or anything
like that so it'd be good to get the see
i i don't i think we should get the
homicide out of the white house and get
like a a a fresh start because we don't
want any more murderers i think we
should just go on to the next question
yeah oh clinton he murdered a guy yeah
you know we're not alone you're not
awesome but i have no accusations with
that that's a little too that's the way
it doesn't work
yeah this is not my week what can i tell
you
oh it's not mine either i'm being very
nice okay
[Music]
be a good boy
now norm do you never hear that no
listen we don't need no one to get into
this and i don't want to hear it and
this is not the place to make those
accusations and you're supposed to be
funny
there you go
this is a live show
but you have been properly chastised by
barbara so i'm not going to ask the next
question i thought it was a matter of
recording
okay let me do this okay
they don't even want to talk about the
fact that maybe the guy murdered
somebody
let's talk football all right
manslaughter
he's doubling down yeah i don't have
norm doesn't play by rules dude that's
hilarious
you know cash back credit cards it's
becoming a thing of the
past bitcoin that's the future that's
what they're saying
block fi
has the world's first bitcoin rewards
credit card that lets you earn an
unlimited 1.5 percent in bitcoin on all
qualifying purchases
whether you're a crypto pro or a total
beginner you can finally earn bitcoin
the easy way with the world's first
bitcoin rewards credit card from blockfi
yep
that's it
wish you got enough bitcoin sooner
blockfi can help
right now our listeners can get a bonus
of 25 in crypto
after you make a first purchase with the
credit card when you sign up at
blockfi.com
theo
that's b l o c k f i
dot com slash t-h-e-o you have a family
member a friend a wife a second wife
and they like that crypto hit him with
this daddy get that item
start earning bitcoin back on your
qualifying purchases today not all will
be eligible
geographic regulatory and underwriting
restrictions apply
fees and terms subject to change
additional term of service at
blockfi.com blackfy is a financial
technology company bank and service
provided by evolve bank and trust member
fdic all your loved ones really want for
the holidays is to see you or to uh or
to just to have a connection you know
and that's why an aura frame can help
um with your aura frame you can give
them access to your frame so they can
upload pictures to you
um so you can be walking down the hall
and bam
you see margaret
you know uploaded them hooters or you
know a nice beat shot
or you see angelica
or somebody frank
uh
put a picture of the kids bam and
there's a video and a surprise and bam
and it's suddenly part of your life and
they did it without you even knowing so
there's a really cool
aura to it i guess to be
just right on the nose
last year aura frames completely sold
out so don't wait
visit aura a-u-r-a-frames
dot-com and get gifting now that's
a-u-r-a-frames.com
listeners use code weekend
to get 30 off auras best selling digital
picture frames
i think comedians don't kind of do you
think that there's a thing
like i noticed this the other day i was
driving with a friend of mine and there
was the traffic was all backed up right
right
and i just go around like it's the
interstate
like there's you know 700 cars in line i
just
go to the outside area where it's not a
street you know yeah and just go
and
my friend's like i just think that he's
a comedian this guy john christen
he's like i think that's just what
comedians do he's like i think you just
see you don't want to do whatever the
conformity is you know
yeah i mean i think that's initially
like how
how it um the genesis of comedy is
going against the grain like when i was
in school
when i was a kid i just would go rogue
to make people laugh
you know so it you're going against the
grain and authority in that sense and
some you know i think a lot of comedians
even if they don't do it on stage they
you know they kind of go rogue yeah but
i mean that's how i was and that's when
i was in key west
again for a year and a half people were
like
like i'm of the ilk of like if somebody
tells me i can't do something i'll be
like
[ __ ] you yeah so when people are like
well you can't just stay in key west and
i go yeah i can do whatever the [ __ ] i
want and all these people are doing that
i'm like you know you're making it way
worse when you keep telling me that i
can't do that
and i just my family and my friends are
like so i mean i don't understand so
you're just gonna just stay there and
i'm like if i want to yeah like yeah
[ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] doing whatever
with my life you know i'm not hurting
anybody i'm like just chilling on an
island
do you uh do you
do you think you'll retire there do you
have a retire spot is a retire like a
real thing i mean i might yeah i really
loved it i really really loved it and it
was cool they said a really nice thing
to me because like after a while you
know at first people like nick sports
and the [ __ ] you doing here yeah
and there was a bar
and they had like a celebrity like wall
of fame
and they had pictures of people who had
been there and i was like oh
i've been in key west for a while i go
hey do you want do you want my picture
and the guy who manages it goes no man i
go what do you mean he goes because
you're just nick you're a friend nick we
don't look at you like actor or comedian
you're just our buddy nick because
everybody kind of thinks that on the
island like you're just nick
and it was like really cool and like
that's why i loved it and like i'd walk
down the street people like hey nick and
i'm like hi
it's like awesome that's cool man they
have a lot of dogs which i like like
they let bar like dogs in bars
yeah so you could go to like a barn and
be like seven dogs it'd be so exciting
and if you can't even talk to anybody if
somebody's just you can't somebody's
just impossible to talk to you just pet
start petting stuff yeah yeah i knew
people's dog's names more than
sure
which was weird
and is it did you feel me that i feel
like it's just i i heard also there's no
beach there it's not like a good beach
in key west is that true there's not
a like a great beach there's like one or
two how do you beat key west and not
have a beach though no it is weird and
that's kind of a misconception because i
was the same way i'm like where the [ __ ]
like you can make where's the thing
where's the thigh tied up the big thing
i got to see some [ __ ] hips slam
against each other oh yeah i know what
you're saying man you know that's i
showed up and i'm like
where's that [ __ ] what are them
[ __ ] [ __ ] raps i'm ready to sniff
some [ __ ] bunk out here yeah i want
to [ __ ] shoot at cumbrilla
just [ __ ] shoot it up and everybody
gathers on the [ __ ] beach
but no it's a it's a lot about going on
the boat that's where like the big thing
is when you go out to sand bars and
there's beaches out there
and so like boating is a big thing
everybody's got a boat and they got a
golf cart so you travel by golf cart oh
i like that which is [ __ ] dope as
[ __ ] and is there a lot of nudism out
there i also hear it's like a nudist
colony is there some of that
no it was not a nudist calling could you
do it one of my sisters did drugs one
time and climbed up to a nudist colony
on accident she was mountain climbing
with a friend she said she was she was
on drugs but um that's those should not
go together drugs
and they climbed up to some place what
drug was it you know i mean if it's
cocaine you're like oh i didn't i don't
know i couldn't it's like i think it was
a smokeable drug
but not weed so
something
but um she goes uh and she
yeah and she doesn't even tell like a
funny story she was like we went
climbing and next you know we had to
have lunch at that nudist colony
apparently they got to like uh
some place where they had like some
nudes up there some you know on top of a
mountain or like at a uh
flat area that's along like by mountain
you know what i'm talking about a
prolapsed [ __ ] yeah i mean it could
be i think that's what it's called
damn the old p laps huh
that's [ __ ] weird so did they have to
get naked
uh i don't think so i didn't [ __ ] did
i bet she did she was high on some
[ __ ]
jerry mathers
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude she was [ __ ] higher
hopefully she had that little front
skunk out you know what i'm saying bro
what is that i don't know this is my
sister can we not talk about this you
[ __ ] brought her up dude you're
[ __ ] drunk you're a drug addict
extreme you're the one who's trying to
lead the country to an island that's not
even an island what do you mean trying i
went to the [ __ ] thing and it is an
island but they built a bridge so people
from miami can [ __ ] od
it's not an island there man it's an
island dude an island you can't get
there bro unless you meet a man who
[ __ ] runs a smoothie business and has
a boat dude dude now you're man island
ding
it's like mansplaining but it's [ __ ]
why does the man have to take you there
that could be why can't it be a lesbo
i'm sure there's some hearty man dude i
uh
let's see if another video question came
in anything else here we got for nick
see i'm gone two years and now i'm not
in demand anymore oh we got a ton of
them oh look at [ __ ] gary
is this written yo nick to the power of
two
i just wanted to ask you guys what was
the most influential sports moment you
guys have seen either live or on
television that really got you up out of
your chair got your vocal cords going
for me it was the seattle seahawks
beating the packers
uh in the nfc championship in like
overtime
but they don't win anymore so it's kind
of hard to um i got a little chatty at
the end but seemed like a nice guy thank
you kyle rittenhouse
kyle's the dude that's gonna like wait
no his name is his name kyle i think so
that guy um it seems like the dude who's
like when you're too drunk at the party
he's like i'm not drinking man i'll take
you home yeah he'll give you a ride he's
like sober cab dude yeah that's a
compliment that's like safe friend dude
yeah let's say friend he's the guy who
would get murdered by somebody
for being a nice guy you know yeah he's
the guy that like oh that guy's got a
flat tire and then they pull over to
help him and then the tire iron just
goes next thing you know
yes jaws [ __ ] alcatraz yeah next
thing you know you got a flat heart bro
you had a flat heart rate
your brain just ran out of air dude
you got psy dude nobody [ __ ] knows
that i try to flex seal this [ __ ] dude
i just put a cannon on the way here man
did you really i have 50 psi right now
one of my tires that [ __ ] is ready to
bust
oh dude yeah
yeah boy oh to answer your question
um the last time i lost my mind i was in
oh uh in denver when i was supposed to
do those shows and i was at the bar at
the hotel and i'm watching the vikings
play the saints in the playoffs i'm a
big vikings fan of
minnesota
and uh
they [ __ ] did that crazy catch casey
keenum to stuff on diggs
and i the bar is full and nobody's
watching the game because it's denver so
i'm watching it and i'm like oh my god
and then i i've rarely done this i just
started screaming and i fell down on my
knees and i put my hands over my head
and i was like oh my god and i started
to tear up and then everybody thought
that i was having like a problem like a
heart attack or like an aneurysm oh yeah
so people were like whoa
whoa man hey hey hey and then the
bartender who i know i've stayed there
for [ __ ] ever and he was like no no
he's from minnesota they just scored
like a crazy [ __ ] play like all time
insane
and everybody's like oh jesus and i was
like
i just lost my [ __ ] i really lost it
that's one of the biggest i've lost what
about you you're a saints fan aren't you
i can't hear you
my other favorite was against the saints
and kyle rudolph called it a touchdown
dude
who died
this guy that's a guy in your living
room the next week
and then the vikings blow it so it all
evens up um
i
you know what i was pretty burned that
was one of the worst moments ever as a
saints fan for sure because yeah that
had to be awful i paused the game for
the fourth quarter for like it was later
i think three and a half minutes left
and i stopped the game because i had to
do my podcast because i had to get it
out for the next day right right so
towards the end of the i figure i'm just
gonna watch into the game when i get
done we're up by 10 you know we're up by
and you guys had the ball so i was like
oh we got this we're going to move on to
the next round
and then my brother called i saw him
kept calling so actually put the call
into the episode
and i was like what's going on he's like
man
you just you're not going to believe
this and we might even maybe put the
clip in if we do it'll be right here but
he's like they did some
type of play and the angle the defensive
guys had it just and we lost the game
and i'm like how did we [ __ ]
it was impossible when you entered your
dvr and we're like hello darkness my
friend
well we didn't even do a crazy everybody
he just went low and stefan jumped over
him or he should have just gone in full
body yeah he just tried to do like a
little
i think it's called a falcon crest yeah
and uh
yeah i felt bad for the defenders i did
too that [ __ ] was horrible but the best
player i've ever seen i was there when
kobe scored 81 points i remember um that
was kind of an interesting time that's
the only laker game i've ever been to
actually
and what else dude oh
you know sandler's making a movie about
sean payton kevin james is playing sean
payton i almost i i was just like
he could have gone in for that [ __ ] he
played sean payton's wife or something
my [ __ ] is concubine
i don't know if he is a concubine i
could have played alvin kamara maybe or
yeah drool breeze if i'd have been in a
freaking wheelchair
what true breezes do no drool breeze
say if drew brees got hit by like a car
or something
oh like an ultimate you're just gonna
change the whole like storyline yeah an
alternate universe there's a guy named
jewel breeze yeah but he still plays i
mean
i mean he's like
they want him to play but he can't you
know but he still does because he's
drool breeze he's like the stephen
hawking of footballers kind of right you
know he's like left blue 53
and he just has like a t-shirt cannon
instead of like an arm so just like
and it just shoots the ball every place
is a hail mary
that would be a [ __ ] amazing movie
dude we just wrote a [ __ ] hit movie
oh we're good yeah i actually i got
already going i didn't go in i should
have
canceled it probably
you at a podcast
probably
because podcast is in my control it's
like i like to do stuff that's in my
control you know i actually might start
a podcast really yeah
everybody's just been telling they're
like why don't you do one
and i'm like i don't know because i just
it's hard doing the road and filming so
it'd be nice to just
do a pod did you get plastic surgery
while you were down there no why your
eyes look more like magnetic kind of i
got magnets in my eyes is that what you
mean oh that could have been it yeah
they injected
magnesium really are you a ah
avalon yeah are you an evangelical
christian correct damn yeah i'm also an
x-men now
yeah
oh you mean you get a you get a
you got the sexual reconstructive
surgery correct
yeah and then also i have magnets in my
eyes
so um if there's somebody's a robot near
me my eyes go right on their dick
or vagines
yeah it's exciting
do you think we'll still have comedy in
the future nick do you think that this
is something that's going to be around
for a while you know you start to see um
a comedian died the other day this guy
met billin
bilin bylan i think
i don't know matt bailin
what prompted do you think comedy will
be around in the future
yeah i don't know say that when are
people gonna not like laughing well
because here's what's happening robots
well they can they have so much um
[Music]
they can create everything now so it's
like at a certain point you're still
gonna need people when they could just
create a bot of a human you know what
i'm saying like
comedy bot or what do you mean well like
they're just starting to create like so
anyway this comedian that passed away
matt bilon bylan
uh
balone balloon maybe billing right
i looked the other day i went on
facebook i put matt balloon death right
because i was just trying to find out
what had happened to him i didn't i just
heard
and there were all these articles that
were written but they were written by
bots
so it's like oh that's interesting now
like because some of it didn't make
sense it would have like some
information and then like a ad for like
zales like written right into the typing
you know what i'm saying right it's
gross
but it's like five of the six things i
even found about him passing away were
written by
bots why don't you just call somebody
that's a comic right i agree but i just
started stand up comic yeah but yeah but
it's just interesting that inform like
bots are writing articles now and some
of the articles
they it was you got the g you under you
you know it was information without the
information yeah yeah no well that's
like no discount but you got the
information
but that's like thing about instagram
too is like i would
meet people or friends of mine that are
like whatever personalities but i would
look on their instagram and like
they have
200 000 followers i'm like that's
[ __ ] crazy i didn't know they were
[ __ ] crushing it that hard yeah and
then i would like click on a photo i'm
like oh it's cool photo and there'll be
all these comments i would like click
and i'm like
but
they would be like hey
awesome picture
have a great day yeah bubble and all
these like comments from like who the
[ __ ] is this and then i'll click on it
and then a couple of my friends i called
out i'm like bro
there's who is zbop zozo z like somebody
yeah
like you're not even using my holes
that's what it'll say something like
that you're like
what that would be amazing if there was
like a system that would sell you like
bot comments but it was just they could
say whatever they want
yeah i feel like it's a lot of bots out
there i just [ __ ] your mom what do you
think comedy will be like in the future
i mean where do you see it do you think
it'll always be around or do you think
stand-up comedy or it too could you
bought it out stand-up comedy
yeah of course
because there's nothing like seeing a
live show there's just nothing like it
yeah when you see a comic live
you know you don't know what's what's
gonna happen it's [ __ ] awesome but
they what about all those people that
died at that one event recently you see
that thing that travis scott thing
was he doing stand up no he's just
singing but no yeah that was awful those
people got crushed
i saw a video of like that at a soccer
match in england and it's one of the
worst i wish i could unsee it and it was
a [ __ ] mob pushing against the gate
and it was like a [ __ ] almost like a
cheese grater these people are just
smashed and they all like tons of people
died it was awful oh
that's just so sad that's why i like i
don't wanna have kids dude i don't wanna
send them off to a [ __ ] concert
and then they're dead what concert will
you take them to what was your first
concert radiohead oh really yeah it was
dope what the hell am i doing here
yeah
god they were good it was at a small
club at prince's club called first
avenue
it's not small but it's like you know
300 400 people
and uh
they that their new album the best
concert is that now it's not bunkers but
bunkers i went to bunkers a couple weeks
ago
oh yeah you were just there
but uh yeah and so i saw my buddies you
wanna go see this band radiohead i'm
like do they sing that song creep and
he's like yeah i'm like all right and he
goes yeah they have a new album called
the benz and we went it was [ __ ]
insane yeah and then i was like hooked
on going to concerts that's the thing
about live shows
with comedy like
support like your clubs and go see live
comedy yeah there's nothing like it it's
so fun there's nothing like it there's
nothing like it and you might find a
little [ __ ] diamond in the rough yeah
like i used to bring comics that i
would meet that were funny dates
that were funny as [ __ ] you know oh yeah
like i had zach galifianakis open for me
i had like a lot of people that you
don't know what you're going to see it's
like a band when you go oh that band's
great and somebody'll be like oh yeah i
wanted to bring you to the concert
like i saw the white stripes you know
there
oh yeah [ __ ] dope
yeah and i was really hyped to con oh
yeah music back then i had two tickets
to the white stripes at the el rays
great venue it's like a third full like
this is just before they broke but i
knew him i was a [ __ ] hip as [ __ ]
dude yeah
and uh i went and it was like it's that
third full wow and i i couldn't even
give the ticket away i'd call people
and then years later my friends would
listen to him and i'm like yeah i had
the ticket i called you yeah you didn't
care and then i [ __ ] took a brick
mushroom in your head you're measuring
your head in your [ __ ] eyes you're
measuring your hair brick to the eye dog
there's a mirror in your head mm-hmm
let's see one more question that came up
man and then we'll get you out oh wow
i just came urine oh help is it
christmas already
what's the question this guy's doing
well right here see that's what i'm
talking about this cove yo what up nick
and theo it's your boy dan calling from
up here in northern maine
nick i gotta would you rather for you
okay would you rather be able to read
people's mind or would you rather be
able to see into the future
dio appreciate you love you baby gang
gang baby thank you of a north main i
hope to go to bangor sometime uh in in
may that's one of the only states i've
ever been to
let me answer your questions see into
the future
how far into the future we gotta
work on that
read people's minds
future would kind of freak me out the
mind i could kind of like learn from but
the future i don't know if i want to
know the future yeah because that's
it's like but again how far into the
future so let's [ __ ] work on that
but um i'm gonna go with um
now [ __ ] it i'm gonna go with reading
the future because if you read
somebody's mind you know it couldn't be
like literally sometimes i'll just think
of weird [ __ ] yeah what if the guy's an
idiot and you're stuck with them forever
or what if what if this whatever you're
but it's only two paragraphs yeah damn
this month it's just like dude what
ah you're called dog yeah
oh dude those guys that's our [ __ ]
job bro those guys
[ __ ] brendan shaw literally looks
like a [ __ ] love seat
[Laughter]
he bought a corvette that's what it
looks like he looks like if white claw
were a person
like the drink white claw
yeah he looks like the abominable white
claw man yeah that's what he looks like
he loves brian and bryan he looks like
paul bunyan's gay little son dude he
looks like paul dudd like he'll [ __ ]
just act here he'll he'll just axe right
through his own butt he'll axe bodies
for you
to death
all right i got rolo yeah
i think we covered it man so is it safe
to say that you're back in the business
i think so i think i'm back so i'm just
getting it all together right now
[ __ ] sober kai again are you yep how
long you been sober for
[Music]
me months wow congratulations man yeah
well actually you know what we have one
more question since that i know one of
the questions that came in that was good
um
let's get it in here
what's up theo what's up nick this is
paul from virginia
um
i know both you guys in the past have
struggled with
drugs and alcohol
and
[Music]
myself as well
fell victim to the dark arts recently
and i'm going into
residential rehab
here in a couple days so i was just
curious if you guys had any advice for
someone
trying to achieve
long-term sobriety thanks gang gang
dang baby
okay i mean do you want to take it or do
you want me to jump in first i think
whatever and
we can also if you i mean i just felt
like this is we could try to just share
anything or experience you
know i mean it's tricky it depends upon
a is it drugs and alcohol
drugs which drug
you know what i mean i've done every
drug you've probably done every drug
yeah i think i have i never smoked crack
i've smoked crack you have yeah i
haven't done heroin i haven't done here
we need i always wanted to smoke crack
i did it like kind of on accident yeah i
only did it once and i was like oh it's
this and then i was like what and
they're like that's crack and i'm like
why i can't feel my lips you can hear
the trainer coming that's what i hear if
i i just hear it's all aboard dude that
crack train boy i know [ __ ] spray
hound too dude welcome all aboard the
spray hound you will just start i mean i
heard you can't even stop just the ejac
from coming out of you i don't know i
just i did it i just saw an accident
once and i was like i don't
accidental crack
yeah i was like already kept up and
somebody hand me a pipe it was [ __ ]
glass
and i thought it was [ __ ] there's
some white [ __ ] in it and i'm like oh
what's this thing i want to smoke till
my [ __ ] wife and kids are gone that's
what i want to do i mean yeah why not
but yeah it was a car accident yeah yeah
it was it let's go well now let's take
this seriously but uh yeah yeah i mean
you know it it really depends upon
you and you know i'm not a [ __ ]
doctor but in my experience which is
kind of what you asked
it's tricky i mean
that's an understatement but you've got
to just really
i had to pull back a lot because i i've
been hospitalized a couple times um for
alcohol
and i had to really get a grip on
what i wanted out of my life and really
take time for myself and you know it
sounds corny but love yourself and
appreciate yourself and the people that
care about you and just look at the big
picture and it's you know
i've seen a lot of people go the
opposite and
not make it out you really have to
figure out what you want to do i mean do
you
i don't know
that's a really messy answer but
no i think it's a good point that's a
great that's a great answer i think
because that really determines it it's
not up to any invisible power i mean it
could be up to god if you need to find a
higher power to help you
but um
but yeah i think trying to have some
semblance of what your goal is for
yourself because a lot of times i find
if i'm not if i'm goalless
and i don't have any real intention then
i'm much more likely to fall into the
dark arts really for me you know right
if i'm just letting the world affect me
however and i don't have a plan every
day when i kind of wake up
then of course i'm gonna fall prey to
whatever and there's a lot of dark
forces out there man
you know freaking everything man
yeah anything will pull you in it's
really i mean
in my experience
i
i've gone back and forth with alcohol
and i've been on podcasts and talked
about it i've been hospitalized and
whatnot and
i finally just had to
find a reason and goals like theo said
where i'm like
you know this is what i want to do you
gotta like care about yourself and stuff
like that and drugs are different so i
don't know what
drugs you're into but in my experience
it was alcohol and drugs drugs just that
just made me feel like [ __ ]
like when i would i did coke you know a
handful of times
you've had the for a handful they have
yeah a handful many times
but
yeah it's oh i'll eat a squirrel from
the backside on coke dude that stuff
will really my god don't do that
you will start at the back of an animal
sonny and get to know it but you've got
to want to help yourself you really do
like if if you
you know you just reach out seek help if
you need it and
but you really really really it comes
down to you and wanting to
to
get help and get off that [ __ ] man and
it's easier said than done but i've been
down that road
and sometimes it takes a wake-up call
and i had a couple and sometimes you
[ __ ] don't wake up a lot of my
friends you know i mean you've had
friends who have died i've had
half of the comedian friends i know i
mean it's just
it's just sad
you know especially in the pandemic it's
been a tough time for a lot of people
yeah i think look yeah i mean i find
that 12 step has helped me
you know i remember all different yeah
yeah i'm thinking about going to a place
in january for a couple weeks just to
even just get i'm not even struggling or
anything right now but just to have some
time for myself to take care of myself
you know i've spent so much time working
as well yeah it's like i've never sat
and thought what's even going on in my
life or what do i want do i want me a
family or something get me a little
armadillo yeah give me a little
armadillo bro something for your arm you
know or armadillo you know
i'm a dylan so yeah get a couple damn
well good luck man and hang in there
it's a process dude but you just yeah
really
just you can do it yeah you can do it
man here's the thing other people have
done it
so you can definitely do it yeah you'll
meet a lot you'll meet a ton of people
it's you know it's more than you think
of people that have struggled with abuse
so
you know reach out and
yeah be well man yeah good luck man you
got this bro
you got this some residential treatment
um all right man nick schwartzen welcome
back welcome back to the world baby yeah
good to be back um and we'll put you up
on social so people can find you and all
of that and
and uh
man i'm excited to see you back on stage
and stuff i know i'm interested to see
what's gonna happen i
two years is a long time yeah it is rock
the mic it's awesome though
gang baby gang
[Music]
oh but when i reach
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my own
and these rails that i've been riding on
there
[Music]